can we all agree that you know
as a woman you're your fertility rate
you know lowers as you get older right
right so the order you get the less
likely you are to obtain a man most
likely because a man is looking for some
a woman that can give him kids right
that makes sense right so that's what
they are looking
to look there that don't want kids so
that's that's what I mean that's what I
meant when I was doing the percentages
before and you said uh where is this
going right we can't go off of the
minority right as a majority most men
look at the woman oh me and this woman
compatible once I could go look like
where are we gonna go going forward
right so moving forward from that that's
what that clip meant right 18 to 26 or
whatever that age range means we're not
saying women after 26 are worthless what
they're saying is 18 to 26 is that
optimal range